>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Margaret Sullivan: Good
afternoon, I'm Margaret Sullivan.
I'm the media columnist
for The Washington Post.
The Post is a charter
sponsor of the Library
of Congress National Book Festival.
We want to thank the sponsors,
in particular David Rubenstein.
You can support the festival with
a donation, there's information
in your program and
you're urged to do so.
Another piece of information is
that this presentation will have
a question and answer period.
There are microphones at
the end of these aisles
and you're urged to take part.
And there is a book signing at 5
o'clock, I think it's at 5 o'clock.
There's a book signing,
I think it's at 5.
Peter Cozzens recently retired
as a Foreign Service Officer
at the State Department
after 30 years.
While at State he wrote 17 books on
the Civil War and the American West.
His new book is "The Earth
is Weeping: The Epic Story
of the Indian Wars for
the American West".
A starred review from Booklist
called the book 'A magnificent
single-volume account of
the post-Civil War conflicts
that shaped our history and
the mythology of the frontier'.
Cozzens' books have all
been selections of the Book
of the Month Club, the History Book
Club or the Military Book Club.
I introduce to you Peter Cozzens.
[ Applause ]
>> Peter Cozzens: Thank you
so much for all coming out
and as you all know as I do the
green is like the head [laughter].
You know I was watching the other
night some pundits on a network
that shall remain nameless, pundits
who shall also remain nameless,
discussing the president's
decision to add more troops
to our conflict in Afghanistan.
And they were speaking of it as of
course already the longest conflict
in American history and that's
not quite, not quite true.
Actually, the longest conflict
in our nation's history
involving the United Stated Army,
were the Indian Wars.
They lasted 101 years, beginning
in 1790 and running through 1891.
Now, before I get into my talk I
thought I should orient us briefly
on the period of the Indian
wars that I'll be discussing
and which my book covers.
My book is devoted to the 25 years
of struggle following the Civil War,
the climatic Indian Wars
of the American West
that really shaped the modern West.
And the conflicts in my
book cover the area ranging
from the Missouri River
all the way West to Canada,
from the Canadian border
and the Pacific Northwest
down into Northern Mexico.
That is essentially the area
that is covered in the book.
Now of all this, you know we're
in a book festival today I'd
like to begin my remarks
with a scene from the movies.
Does anyone recognize
this movie scene offhand?
Okay, by the applause
I gather you do.
This of course is Dustin Hoffman
as a very befuddled army scout
watching George Armstrong Custer
preening himself before the
Battle of the Little Bighorn.
I guess he wanted to look
good before he was killed.
This scene from "Little Big Man"
came to have an allegorical meaning
to me as I was researching the book.
Custer, Dustin Hoffman actually I
kind of came to feel somewhat akin
to him as I delved into the subject.
And Custer for me came to personify
the mythos of the Indian Wars,
the many myths that
surround the Indian Wars.
Now, to some degree of course
myth always distorts history
but I believe that the Indian Wars
of the American West are uniquely
susceptible to this phenomenon.
Much of both popular
and academic history,
film and fiction has depicted the
period as an absolute struggle
between good and evil, reversing
the roles of heroes and villains
as necessary to accommodate a
changing national conscience.
Now in the first 80 years following
the tragedy at Wounded Knee in 1891
which ended the Indian Wars,
the nation had a tendency
to lionize the Indian
fighting army and to vilify
or to trivialize the Indians
who resisted "civilization".
In 1970 the story reversed
itself and the pendulum swung
in the opposite direction,
to the opposite extreme.
Americans were developing an acute
sense of the countless wrongs
that had been done to
the American Indian.
Dee Brown's elegantly written and
passionately wrought "Bury My Heart
at Wounded Knee" and
later that same year,
the film "Little Big
Man" shaped a new saga
that articulated the
nation's feelings of guilt.
In the public mind the
government and the army became seen
as wilful exterminators of the
native peoples of the West.
In "The Earth is Weeping" I have
tried to bring historical balance
to the story of the Indian Wars.
The first step to presenting
a balanced history is,
I believe is, to strip
away the myths.
There are too many myths for
us to discuss them all today,
what I'd like to do then, is I hope
wet your appetite for the book,
by addressing what I consider to
be the three most egregious myths
and most commonly-held myths
surrounding the Indian Wars.
And here they are, the
first one, myth one,
that the regular army was
hell-bent on killing Indians.
Myth two, that government Indian
policy was exterminationist
and three, that the Indians
united to resist the Whites,
to resist white encroachment
on their lands.
So, let's begin with the fallacy,
what I argue is a fallacy,
that the regular army was
eager to kill Indians.
Does anyone recognize
this jaunty fellow?
This is George Crook and he was one
of the premier Indian
fighting generals in the West.
He doesn't look like
much of a general,
he never wore a uniform out West.
He usually dressed in a pith
helmet and civilian clothes
and rode a mule, and was
less military-looking
than the common soldiers.
But he was without a
doubt one of the two
or three finest generals
fighting the West.
And during the height of
the Indian Wars, a reporter,
a newspaper reporter asked
him how he liked his job.
And Crook replied, not much.
He said it was a hard thing to be
forced to do battle with Indians
who more often than
not were in the right.
As Crook continued, he said I do
not wonder and you will not either
that when Indians see their
wives and children starving
and their last source of
supplies cut off, they go to war.
And then we are sent
out there to kill them.
It is an outrage.
All tribes tell the same story.
They are surrounded on all sides.
The game is destroyed
or driven away.
They are left to starve and there
remains but one thing for them
to do, to fight while they can.
Our treatment of the
Indian is an outrage.
Now, that a general would offer such
a candid and forceful public defence
of the Indians may strike some of
you, as it did me, as implausible
because it contradicts
an enduring myth,
that the regular army was the
implacable foe of the Indian,
and they wanted to go
out and kill Indians.
And Crook was far from being
the only high-ranking officer
to protest the injustices
that were done to the Indians.
John Pope, who was then the
commander of the huge Department
of the Missouri, which encompassed
nearly half the West actually
suggested at one point
that soldiers be sent
to help the Indians eliminate
white buffalo hunters.
The year was 1874.
The buffalo hunters had decimated
the herds of Western Kansas
and early that year they began, they
set up shop in the Texas Panhandle
at a place called Adobe Walls and
resumed the killing of buffalo
on Indian reservation land,
buffalo that had been promised
the Indians in perpetuity.
When 500 warriors attacked
the despised buffalo hunters
at Adobe Walls in June 1874
the governor of Kansas appealed
to General Pope to dispatch
troops to save the white men.
Pope turned the governor down flat.
Indians like white men, he said, are
not reconciled to starve peacefully.
The buffalo hunters have justly
earned all that has befallen them.
If I were to send troops to this
unlawful establishment it would be
to break it up and
not to protect it.
Unfortunately the buffalo
hunters managed
to repel the Indians on their own.
Now, from these two episodes,
what are we to conclude?
And the essential truth
is that the plight
of the Indians deeply disturbed most
senior officers and then more often
than not they sympathized with the
hostile Indians whey were charged
with subduing.
I could give countless more examples
of other generals who
felt the same way.
Now, what can we say about
the government policy
that they were charged
with enforcing?
Its wisdom or morality may be
questioned but it cannot be said
that the government ever intended to
physically exterminate, I emphasize,
physically exterminate the Indians.
That the Indian way of life must
be eradicated, if the Indians were
to survive, was however
taken for granted,
even among the most ardent
advocates of Indian rights.
The term, the phrase
'kill the Indians,
save the man' was quite common then.
Well, federal Indian policy
after the Civil War
evolved in fits and starts.
When the Civil War ended,
it was in absolute tatters.
Neither the president
nor Congress were able
to fashion a coherent
policy which left things
as General William Tecumseh Sherman,
who was the ranking
officer the West,
put it to "caprice and hazard".
Another great problem was
rampant corruption that ran
through the Indian Bureau.
This slide here is the
famous Thomas Nast cartoon
from Harper's Weekly
showing a starving Indian
and a quite satisfied
and heavily-laden with
cash Indian agent.
There was a popular story told of
a chief who described his agent
to General Sherman thusly.
He said, 'Our agent great man,
when he comes he brings
everything in a little bag.
When he goes it takes
three steamboats
to carry away his things'.
Well, things changed in 1869
with the newly-elected
President Ulysses S. Grant
who famously declared with respect
to the Indians 'Let us have peace'.
He instituted a 'carrot and stick'
policy, a carrot and stick body
of principles that became
known as the Peace Policy.
Grant replaced the corrupt agents
with churchmen and army officers.
He also established independent
oversight of the Indian Bureau.
And he directed the Indian
agents to assemble the Indians
in their jurisdictions on permanent
reservations that were well removed
from the overland travel routes
and from white settlements,
get them started on the
road to "civilization"
and above all treat them
with kindness and patience.
Indians who refused to settle
on reservations would be turned
over to the military however and
treated as friendly or hostile
as circumstances might justify.
Now, kindness and patience,
not to mention common decency,
were often lacking in the
implementation of Grant's policy.
In the ensuring years some of
the reforms that he instituted
like replacing these
patronage agents were abandoned
and the corruption resumed.
But the principles that Grant
promulgated officially guided Indian
policy during the 25 years of the
Indians Wars of the American West.
The end result as we
all know, however,
was to dispossess Indians
of their lands.
The question then naturally
arises, how did the Indians respond
to the broken promises,
the broken treaties
and to the relentless white
encroachment on their lands?
And that brings us to the third
enduring myth that I want to,
if not dispel, at least cause
you to think about this afternoon
and that is the notion
that the Indians united
to resist white encroachment.
Does anyone recognize this
kind of art, this type of art?
>> Ledger art.
>> Peter Cozzens: Ledger
art, exactly, this,
Indian warriors beginning in the
mid-19th century developed a type
of art called Ledger art where they
would take ledger books and draw
or paint in them what
they considered
to be their most heroic
deeds as warriors,
deeds that they considered
most worthy
of remembering and passing on.
And invariably they were
nine times out of ten,
pictures of them killing
Indians of other tribes.
This picture you see here is
of a Cheyanne Indian
warrior running his lance
through a Pawnee Indian warrior.
And it graphically I think
illustrates the point
that the Indians not
only failed to unite
in opposing the westward
expansion of civilization
but they also continued to
make war on one another.
And the reason for that was simply
that these were warrior cultures.
Inter-tribal warfare was too deeply
ingrained for them to do otherwise.
A young man raised in a tribe in
the West, he owed his whole place
in tribal society to his
success as a warrior.
In some tribes a young man
could not even court a girl
until had brought home war honors.
So, unfortunately there was no
sense of Indian-ness that we,
the Indians were a common
people until it was,
until it was far too late.
And during the course of the
Indian Wars an army officer asked a
Cheyanne chief why his tribe preyed
on their Crow Indian neighbors?
Well, he said, we stole the
hunting grounds of the Crows
because they were the best.
We wanted more room.
It was as simple as that.
Or, as a Lakota chief, Lakota Sioux
chief told a government treaty
negotiator, he said "You have
split my land and I do not like it.
These lands once belonged
to the Kiowa and to the Crow
but we whipped those
nations out of them
and in this we did
what the white men do
when they want the
lands of the Indians".
Well those certainly were sentiments
that inquisitive Whites determined
to clear the West of
what they considered
to be troublesome Indians,
could readily appreciate.
Now one side point that I want to
make, that I haven't made enough
in the past, is that while the
Indians fought among themselves
relentlessly and throughout this
whole epic of their dispossession,
the Indians never provoked any
of the conflicts with the Whites
that you'll read about in my book.
They never provoked any of them.
They were always driven to war and
I think showed remarkable restraint.
A kind of a subtext
of this third myth,
something that's frequently
lost in the mythos
of the Indian Wars are
the numerous tribes
that actually accepted
the white presence,
that actually welcomed the white
presence because it enabled them
to form allies to fight
their own tribal enemies,
sort of along the lines of 'the
enemy of my enemy is my friend'.
The Pawnee Indians for
example were vitally important
to the construction of the
Transcontinental Railroad,
specifically the Union-Pacific
Railroad.
In the summer of 1867 the
Lakota and the Cheyanne had
so severely raided the Union-Pacific
that they essentially brought work
on the road to a standstill,
to an absolute halt.
The army proved incapable of
stopping these fast-moving,
fast-riding Indian raiding
parties and so a battalion
of Pawnees were recruited
as soldiers.
Here you see a picture of the Pawnee
battalion preparing for action.
Well the Pawnee battalion, how many
of you have watched
"Hell on Wheels"?
The series, I imagine
a good number of you.
Well noticeably absent in "Hell
on Wheels" is any mention
of the Pawnee.
But they mauled one large Cheyanne
war party so badly that raids
on the Union-Pacific
stopped, completely stopped
and work resumed unimpeded.
I think it's safe to
say that the presence
of the Pawnee battalion
along the road shaved
at least a year off the construction
of the Transcontinental Railroad
and probably a season or
two off of "Hell on Wheels".
Now, as destructive as the
fighting between tribes was,
what ultimately doomed the Indians,
doomed Indian resistance was the
inability of individual tribes
to maintain cohesion
against the white threat.
Only those tribes that accepted
the Whites, tribes like the Pawnee,
the Crow, the Shoshone were unified.
None of the tribes that are famous
to us for fighting the government
like the Lakota, the Cheyanne,
the Apache, the Arapaho,
none of these tribes were
ever united for war or peace.
Each tribe had its war and peace
factions that are traditionalist
and accommodation of factions
however you want to name them,
that struggled for dominance
and clashed sometimes
violently with one another.
You get again the traditionalists
or war faction and the peace
or accommodationist
faction in each tribe.
The Kiowa of the Southern Plains
offer a particularly tragic example
of this, of a tribe torn asunder.
The individual you see here
is named Chief Kicking Bird.
He was the head of the
Kiowa peace faction
and he singlehandedly kept nearly
all of the Kiowas out of the,
what was called the Red River
War which was a final struggle
for the Southern Plains and that
followed on the Adobe Walls raid
that I mentioned earlier.
So he kept almost the entire
tribe out of that war.
Nonetheless when the war is
over the government decided
that they would make an
example for a change of Indians
who they felt were responsible
for instigating the war.
And so they ordered Kicking
Bird to select a quota of Kiowa
to be sent east to
Florida for imprisonment.
You know, Kicking Bird
argued that you know,
we played a very small role in it.
Hardly any Kiowa were
ever in the war.
Nonetheless, he was required
to choose a contingent
for incarceration.
So to ease the burden on the tribe
he chose mostly Mexican captives
and tribal delinquents.
That was well and good but he
also chose a vicious war leader
by the name of Mamonti [phonetic]
and Kicking Bird's
complicity cost him his life.
As Kicking Bird saw the prisoners
off with words of affection
and promise that their
incarceration would be brief,
which in fact it was,
Mamonti hexed him.
"You think you have done well.
You think you are free, a
big man with the Whites,
but you will not live
long, I will see to that".
The next day Kicking Bird
died at the age of 39
after drinking a cup of coffee.
The army surgeon who treated
him said he had been poisoned
with strychnine.
There had been a fatalistic element
in Kicking Bird's struggle
to maintain peace.
In the unending hatred
between Whites
and Indians Kicking Bird
foresaw the apocalypse.
"I fear blood must flow and my heart
is sad" he told a Quaker friend
before the Red River War.
"The white man is strong but he
cannot kill us all in one year,
it will take him two or
three, maybe four years
and then the world will
turn to water or burn up.
It is our Mother and cannot live
when the Indians are all dead".
I will close my remarks then
with Kicking Bird's words,
review very quickly the three myths
that we talked about, myth one,
the regular army being the
implacable foe of the Indians,
myth two, that government Indian
policy was exterminationist
in nature and that myth three
that the Indians united
to resist the Whites.
I hope that, I know it is a lot.
We could talk at great
length on this subject
but I hope I've left you a
little less confused and baffled
than our poor friend Dustin
Hoffman here seen looking
up at Custer at the Little Bighorn.
So with that, I will
be more than happy
to answer any questions
you may have, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, with the expansion
of the American population,
the desire for land and of course
cold trapping, et cetera, et cetera,
could these Indian Wars
really have been avoided?
>> Peter Cozzens: Some of them
could have been, if not avoided,
at least ameliorated, because
some of the Indian Wars
like the Nez Perce
War involved tribes
that were already partly
acculturated.
But on the Plains, the Great
Plains where the majority
of the conflict took place I don't
think they could have been avoided
because you had tribes
like the Cheyanne.
The Cheyanne numbered only about
3500 people yet during the time
of which we speak they claimed
as their traditional hunting lands
Eastern Colorado, Western Kansas,
Western Nebraska, Northern
modern-day Oklahoma
and Southern Wyoming.
Now it just wasn't reasonable
to expect the Whites,
you know a population of 38
million to turn over the equivalent
of maybe what, maybe three
modern western states
to 3500 essentially
hunters and gatherers.
So, a good portion affect at least
half of the Plains Indians did try
to make the transition
peacefully to a different way of,
to an agricultural way
of life, but for a number
of reasons the success
was partial at best.
There were strong traditionalist
factions like those led
by Crazy Horse, Sitting
Bull that didn't want
to fight the Whites they just
wanted to pursue their old way
of living and chasing the buffalo.
But that was, unfortunately
that was just.
It was just incongruent with
such a huge western population.
So, some of the conflicts
at least were inevitable
and it was absolutely
inevitable that that way
of life was going to
have to give way.
Yes sir?
>> You look at Western civilization
and you see what happened
when something else different,
events sort of that's happened.
It was Genghis Khan who unified
the Mongols and nomadic tribes
and essentially you know attacked
civilization quite successfully.
At what point, if the Indians
had gotten a leader like that
who could unify them, and would
it have been able to really wipe
out the civilization, seriously
impede it for many centuries?
At what point, would it
be before the Civil War?
Would [inaudible]?
Would it have been
later, at what point?
>> Peter Cozzens: That's
funny you mention Tecumseh,
the book I'm working on right now
is a biography of Chief Tecumseh
and I'll be exploring
that very question.
At what point could the Whites have,
could the Indians perhaps have,
you know united to have, if
not stopped white encroachment,
at least seriously impeded it?
>> One leader?
>> Peter Cozzens: Yeah, one leader.
In the West I think the best chance
would have been before the Civil
War, would have been maybe in the
early 1850s when the, when Whites
and I use the term Whites to mean,
you know, non-Native-Americans,
were crossing the West, were
trying to get to the West coast
for minerals and for the
Pacific Northwest, for land,
and we're not settling the West.
That would have been a time
when I think sufficient costs could
have been, might have been incurred
by the government that
negotiations might have led
to maybe you know one
state, the equivalent
of one state being set
aside for the Indians.
But even that would have been a
tall order because you know disease
and inter-tribal warfare had so
reduced the tribes of the West
that by the time we're talking
about [inaudible] there were no more
than 200,000 Indians
in the West and again,
already at least 3 million
Whites and more on the way.
So, I don't think it was ever,
ever a realistic possibility
quite honestly in the West
because the inter-tribal
hatreds were just so great.
You have a different story
east of the Mississippi.
I think there was a time when
that could have happened,
several cases when it could
have happened but not west
of the Mississippi unfortunately.
>> So, if Tecumseh had been, lived
longer, could he have done it?
>> Peter Cozzens: Ah, stay tuned
for my next book [laughter].
>> Okay.
>> Okay, thank you very much.
I really enjoyed your talk.
>> Peter Cozzens: Thank you.
>> A two-part question, one,
I wondered if you could expand
on your comment that
these tribes tended
to show a lot more
restraint than aggression.
And I'm interested in that
because they were such a martial,
I mean if they had a
[inaudible] culture it was
that they were martial,
particularly on the plains
and so I'm wondering why you
think that they showed restraint.
And then the second
part of my question,
understanding that
you're an historian
and not really telling
us how we should feel
about what you've reported, but
I'm interested in your conclusions
about what the appropriate response
is, should we still feel guilty
as white people here in America or,
what's the appropriate way to look
on this now in the totality of
everybody had a part to play in it.
>> Peter Cozzens: Okay, well look to
the first, to your first question,
interestingly the Indians did
not consider soldiers or Whites
to be particularly worthy opponents
and in fact they had such contempt
for soldiers that they would often
scalp them and just toss the scalp
at the side of the soldier.
And scalping, a scalp was, you
know an important war honor,
not the most important but
it was an important war honor
and they didn't consider the
soldiers to be worthy enemies.
And a lot of the, the government had
a very wise and insipid practice of,
I actually should say,
nefarious military,
it's whatever word you want to use,
the practice of bringing chiefs
from the western tribes
to Washington
and just showing them
what they were facing.
And you know these chiefs
would come out West, out East
and they would go back
to their tribe and say,
my God I've seen giant wigwams,
giant teepees that hold more people
than we have in our tribes.
And that all, that tended to have
an effect, a means of kind of like,
maybe we just can't resist this
and we can't resist this onslaught.
But it was, I think in large
measure it was the former
and that they didn't think the
Whites were worthy opponents
and the culmination of that plus a
lot of them saw the inevitability
of defeat if they did resist.
In answer to your second question,
I mean the answer I'll give will
have to be strictly personal.
And every time I go out West
to, to the Cheyanne reservation
or to say San Carlos, the Apache
reservation and see the poverty
on those reservations and just
to see how bad the land is
that the Indians were allotted,
it just makes my blood boil
and I think, I think that there's
a tremendous ignorance on the part
of Americans as to the
suffering that is endured by many
of the tribes out West today.
So, I think, I think
the continued sense
of national guilt is appropriate.
I think it's very appropriate.
And I think that what happened
with the pipeline should
only compound it.
I think that, I personally think
that was outrageous,
absolutely outrageous.
[ Applause ]
>> Hello, thank you.
This question has two parts
but I'd also like to follow
up on what you just said
regarding the scalping.
Was that something that the
white man started initially?
And the other two parts
of my question were,
in regards to myth number three in,
the support the Indians
getting together.
At the Battle of Little Bighorn
weren't there several different
tribes there?
>> Peter Cozzens: Right.
>> And the last thing I
wanted to ask about was the,
in regards to the status
of the Indians in the West.
Weren't they aware that, you know
the Cherokee Indians had tried
to assimilate much earlier before
during the period of Jackson before
and they have a communication
of knowing how
that had already followed
out that there was no chance
that they were ever going to be
allowed to assimilate in any case?
>> Peter Cozzens: Let me try
to keep all three questions,
that's a lot to keep in my head.
The first question, scalping, that
existed before the first Whites came
but the Whites picked
up on that very quickly
and settlers began scalping Indians.
Rewards were offered
for Indian scalps
and so it was done by both sides.
Your second question about
the Indians who were united
at the Little Bighorn,
you make a very good point
and it's a point I probably
should have made in my remarks,
is that there were tribes
that did form alliances.
For the Little Bighorn it
was basically the Lakota,
the various seven tribes of
the Lakota, that is to say,
the Plains Sioux Indians
and the Cheyanne.
The Lakota and Cheyanne had
a longstanding alliance.
It also included the
Arapaho at one time.
On the Southern Plains the Kiowa
and the Comanche had an alliance.
And the Southern Cheyanne also
allied themselves with the Kiowa
and the Comanche, so there
were these localized alliances
but no overarching Indian alliance.
And your third question, I?
>> It was regarding the
assimilation and the fact that,
you know what happened
to the Cherokee.
>> Peter Cozzens: Oh right,
the assimilation and of the,
the fate of the five
civilized tribes
who were sent out to
Eastern Oklahoma.
They were actually seen as
interlopers by the tribes
in the West and the contact
between the Plains Indians tribe
with the Kiowa, the
Comanche, the Cheyanne,
and the five civilized
tribes, that Jackson had forced
to cross the Mississippi,
was largely hostile.
>> So they didn't know?
I guess what I'm saying.
>> Peter Cozzens: They, they.
>> The history of it [inaudible].
>> Peter Cozzens: I think there was
a sense of awareness among some.
You know I've not.
I've not seen that
topic really explored.
It's an excellent topic
for explorers
to how much peaceful
communication there may have been
between the five civilized
tribes, the Eastern Oklahoma
and the Plains Indian tribes.
Most of it that I'm aware of
was hostile so I don't know,
you know to what extent those
lessons may have been passed on.
>> Thank you.
>> Peter Cozzens: It's
a good question though.
>> Hello, the first
question is about feedback
from the people you wrote about,
the Natives, could you tell us,
you know was it positive or
negative about the Natives
who read your book, you know?
And also, the second question,
is how can we bring healing,
because as you said earlier
that it's very sad out there
and how can we bring healing to
stop the, you know suicide and?
>> Peter Cozzens: I think I
should, sorry to interrupt
but I think I should probably
just answer the first question
because I'm getting a time, you know
time thing and there are more folks
who want to have questions.
And the first question I've
already forgotten, I'm sorry.
This is my fault.
>> Okay, maybe the second
question is more important
because it's dealing
with current issues.
>> Peter Cozzens: I'd
prefer the first.
>> Oh, okay, okay, because the
second question is very hard.
>> Peter Cozzens: It's
a whole, another yeah.
>> It's a lot of gentleness maybe.
But the first question was,
obviously a lot of modern people
in the city are reading this book.
>> Peter Cozzens: Okay, right
they're reading and yeah,
reaction I've gotten
from American-Indians
and I don't use the
term Native-Americans
because all the Indians
I've met prefer to be called
by their tribal name or be called
Indians and they don't care
for the term Native-Americans.
We do have a museum
here in the Mall,
it's called the National
Museum of the American Indian
and that name was selected
by Indians.
I think that's what they prefer.
In any case, the reception I got has
been very good, it's been very good.
In fact the leading American Indian
current events publication used an
excerpt not from my book
but from an article I wrote
in the Smithsonian magazine
about the Black Hills,
the seizure of the Black Hills
as part of their discussion
and arguments against what
was happening with pipeline.
So the reception has been
good and that, that it's been.
It's been considered a fair, a
fair and even-handed approach.
As I said I, in this book, you will
get 50% white people viewpoint,
50% Indian viewpoint.
I've tried to again be
completely down the middle in terms
of representing, you know
both sides to the issue.
>> Quick question, what
percent of the Indians realized
that it was hopeless to stay
at least in the United States
and made their way to Canada?
>> Peter Cozzens: Ah, there
were Indians that did go
to Canada actually
it was the Lakota,
Sitting Bull's assemblage
of Lakota Indians.
After the Little Bighorn campaign
and subsequent fighting made a break
for Canada and about
3000 of them did settle
in Canada for several years.
And they were welcomed by the
government of Canada so long
as they didn't cause
any trouble or raid
across the United States/Canadian
border.
And some of the Nez Perce
who escaped also joined
these Lakota in Canada.
The problem there was that
the buffalo were running
out in Western Canada and the
Canadian tribes were resentful
of the presence of the tribes,
Indians from the United States
encroaching on their buffalo herds.
And so they, I mean the
British government was agreeable
to the Lakota staying.
It took a grand total of a dozen
Royal Canadian Mounted Police
to keep order among 3500 Lakota
which shows how easy it would
have been had it been a different
policy possible.
But it was the Canadian tribes
who put pressure on the Lakota
to get the heck out and
eventually the buffalo did run
out the Lakota were starving
and they eventually had
to make their way into
the United States.
It's a sad story.
>> Thanks.
>> Hi, I wonder if you could talk
about, again about the five tribes
because their territory
belonged to them.
The Indian Wars took
place around them.
The territory of Oklahoma was
left because it belonged to them.
They were a strong alliance and
the state of Sequoia was discussed
on the floor of Congress and so
that period I think is less talked
about by historians
because it's such.
It's not as easy to talk
about it as the Indian Wars
or what happened east
of the Mississippi.
>> Peter Cozzens: Well, right.
>> So, if you could address that.
>> Peter Cozzens: Well,
I'll be rectifying some
of that in my next book.
But, during the period
we're talking about here,
you know the tribes were
settled in Eastern Oklahoma.
None of them lost any land
because of what was happening
in the Indian Wars, on
the Plains, in the West.
They weren't affected
by it directly.
Tribes like the Cherokee and
the Chickasaw lost some land
because parts of those tribes fought
with the Confederacy
during the Civil War
and that's what cost them some land.
>> I think [inaudible] and I have
a book coming out on it next year,
was an excuse to open up land to
settlement so I think that it's.
>> Peter Cozzens: Well.
>> The end of the Indian Wars
made people aware I think
that that land was there
and had not been exploited
by Whites so that's something.
>> Peter Cozzens: Well some of that,
the land west of the
five tribes was given
over to southern Cheyanne,
Kiowa and Comanche.
I am told now to wrap it up.
I apologize gentlemen, maybe we can.
If you go down to the
book signing we can chat.
Thank you very, very much and
I'll be signing books downstairs.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov